and storefronts across the country are
boarding up just ahead of possible
election unrest
a couple businesses in las vegas are
also taking precautions but not all of
them
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the preparations
and also the concerns before tomorrow
night it's business as usual for most
places here in the arts district but
one store did not want to take any
chances of potential civil unrest and
decided to board up the windows
ahead of tuesday we're basically
preparing for the worst but hoping for
the best
taking a proactive approach it's not a
matter of being
paranoid it's a matter of taking matter
into your own hands
courtney olsen puts plywood panels on
her storefront the same boards the girl
clothing owner used
earlier this year when all non-essential
businesses
shut down i'm going to do whatever i can
to do what's best
for myself and my brand and my company
a precaution in case of any election
unrest but
not all businesses plan to take the same
approach we're
boarded up all of quarantine and i don't
want to feel like i'm losing
all my stuff again because of an
election i can't do that
we know las vegas is sane becky miller
is vice president of the arts district
she doesn't worry about potential
violence happening here
i think that las vegas is
a smart community and i do believe that
las vegas
understand that if they want to make a
change that they get involved from the
very beginning
and not just complain about it after the
fact olson though does not want to take
any chances
she stands by her decision no matter
what others think about it
kristen drummond 8 news now we can also
tell you that metro police do plan to
boost their presence tomorrow the
department is going to be opening a
deployment operations center
so they can monitor all the potential if
any potential safety threats
as normally done with big events like
new year's eve for instance
there will also be 600 officers on
standby to help the patrol
division